-Hey, YouTube, here with
his U.S. solo debut performance
of "Like Crazy"
from his new album "Face,"
give it up for Jimin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ She's saying,
"Baby, come and follow me ♪
♪ There's not a bad thing here
tonight ♪
♪ Save your reasons
all for later ♪
♪ Stay with me a little while" ♪
♪ Watch me go ♪
♪ Now, I sink down,
all alone away ♪
♪ Where am I? ♪
♪ A dark haze
clouding up my eyes ♪
♪♪
♪ I can hear the voices
listening ♪
♪ Don't know who they are ♪
♪ And trying to take
the pressure off ♪
♪ Been reaching for the stars ♪
♪ Tell me,
will I find myself again? ♪
♪ When I go too far? ♪
♪ Yeah, I know,
you know, I know ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I'd rather be ♪
♪ Lost in the lights,
lost in the lights ♪
♪ I'm outta my mind ♪
♪ Can you help me
numb the pain? ♪
♪ Each night,
you spin me up high ♪
♪ Emotions on ice ♪
♪ Let me have a taste ♪
♪ Give me a good ride ♪
-♪ Oh, I'm fallin', I'm fallin',
I'm fallin' ♪
-♪ Oh, it's gon' be
a good night ♪
-♪ Oh, I'm fallin' ♪
-♪ Forever, you and I ♪
-♪ Mm-hmm, yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
♪ Mm-hmm, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Mm-hmm ♪
♪♪
♪ All my reflections, I ♪
♪ I can't even recognize ♪
♪ I'm feelin' so alive,
wasting time ♪
♪ I'd rather be ♪
♪ Lost in the lights,
lost in the lights ♪
♪ I'm outta my mind ♪
♪ Can you help me
numb the pain? ♪
♪ Each night,
you spin me up high ♪
♪ Emotions on ice ♪
♪ Let me have a taste ♪
♪ Give me a good ride ♪
-♪ Oh, I'm fallin', I'm fallin',
I'm fallin' ♪
-♪ Oh, it's gon' be
a good night ♪
-♪ Oh, I'm fallin' ♪
-♪ Forever, you and I ♪
♪ This will break me ♪
♪ This is gonna break me ♪
-♪ Break me ♪
-♪ No, don't you wake me ♪
♪ I wanna stay in this dream,
don't save me ♪
♪ Don't you try to save me ♪
-♪ Save me ♪
-♪ I need a way we ♪
♪ I need a way we can dream on ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪♪